good morning guys
just like clockwork every time i start
snorkeling like crazy
my ears get clogged up
and it's so clogged right now i can
barely hear on both sides
and i think um
it's affecting my sinuses too because
you know how like your ear nose and
throat is connected
so like the last two days it kind of
feels like i'm a little seasick which
would be weird from snorkeling right
because you're not really on a boat but
i feel a little bit nauseous just a
little bit just like a layer of like 15
notches last couple days so like i
better get this over with i'm still
being hawaii for a while so i went to
the store and they got some new and
improved stuff this one's called the wax
blaster md
safely cleans the ear canal easy to use
at home doctor recommended
this box is so freaking funny because
like when you look at the packaging
it just looks pretty straightforward
right
like almost like kirkland made it or
like target or cvs made it but watch and
you read the back where it says
directions for use
um step number one is mix one packet of
ear clean md into ten ounces of warm
water shake to dissolve pretty
straightforward then number three
says spray solution into the ear canal
until your ear feels clear and clean one
10 ounce bottle should be enough for
both ears unless you're a basket hound
and wait
can
so it was so funny because all of a
sudden that you don't have a line of
comedy
or the guy that wrote that
is so funny and he doesn't even know
because he didn't say unless you're a
dog
he was so specific unless you're a
basset hound and bastard hounds if you
guys know what those look like
is the dog with the long ears which is
so hilarious
um so yeah i got this
because i'm trying to bang this out real
quick before we head out on the road and
if my ears are really really stuck
together because i haven't swam in a
long time actually you know what i
didn't really get this when i was
swimming on the regular swimming pool
because i think my ear wax was just
flowing in and out and i didn't get a
chance to really harden but since i
haven't swim in a long time i think my
earwax hardens then the water pushes it
in deep inside so i also got this guy
this guy dissolves it but it's going to
take a while so i'm not going to do this
one because this one you got to put in
your ear it's like this little dropper
you put in your ear
and it kind of like takes 15 minutes to
dissolve on both sides so that's like 30
minutes because once you lay down you
can't move so you gotta lay like this
for 15 minutes and then lay like this
for 15 minutes so you can really do both
at the same time so for those of you
guys who uh just randomly go on vacation
or whatever and also your ears feel
stuffed i think it's pretty normal
because if you're not swimming regularly
then your earwax has a time to build up
and then all of a sudden you go
snorkeling then it pushes it in so they
do have stuff to help clear it out i've
been doing this stuff since i was pretty
much in high school
because there's a period of time where i
was like swimming a lot at the beach
boogie board and all that and then i did
i stopped it and then i jumped right
back in like six months later as if i've
been doing the whole time and my ears
get stuck right away and then the school
nurse helped me so i'm gonna be doing
this and hopefully turn out my ears
so this is the stuff that it comes with
has a little ear basin so that you uh
can place it like on your ear so when
you blast your ear the stuff can just go
straight to here or you just do it over
the sink
um and it comes with these packets these
are the ones that says unless you're a
bass at how you only need one so you mix
this this part's really important always
mix it with warm water because the warm
water breaks up like the wax because it
is kind of like waxy right so if it's
warm it kind of melts it out so i
put one packet in here mixed with some
warm water then you got this cool tip
that you you put on and then you just
pretty much just go away and uh i mean
have at it and uh don't spray too hard
because you could pop your eardrums
although this one is really cool because
i think it's manual
um
where it's um
it's adjusted so that you can't have too
much pressure the old school like bubble
one that i have you can't blast your ear
really hard and i remember one time i
felt like i almost blasted my eardrums
apart so um i got to make sure to be
really really careful
all right so i got out as much as i
think i could
if you guys are squeamish
don't look at this
i know there's a bunch of weirdos out
there that like watching pimple pop in
that crazy asmr type stuff if you like
seeing that stuff this is what came out
of my ears
um this solution actually works
because usually it's just one big black
chunk that comes out but i think this
solution actually like
dissolves it so it's not as satisfying
as seeing like some like a big old like
chunk that comes out but there's like
lots of little pieces that are melted
and then also
there's this part where i was like
wiping my ear so this big little chunk
so
there you go you weirdos um that's how
it works
i'm still gonna i still feel a little
bit of liquid in there but at least it's
way more clear than before i think
tonight i'm going to use the the this
one the more intensive one because i'll
really break it up and i'll spray it
again and i'm kind of dizzy a little bit
too you know your ears are like your
you're like
your equalizer your balancing
mechanism i feel kind of lightheaded but
i'm gonna finish this bottle i'm almost
done
and then
should be ready to go hopefully so today
we're about to head to this secret
turtle beach
where apparently there are just tons of
turtles like everywhere up and down and
side to side and they're just eating
hanging chilling and doing all that so
it's a secret local spot so i don't want
to burn it out but before we go there we
are hungry so we're gonna grab some
yummy snacks
tuna mayo
so they usually have some quick grab
ones right here but if they run out then
they can make some fresh ones
what is that chicken
oh yeah
monkey papa so they're making ours uh
fresh right now so in the meantime get
some yummy food in between i'm sorry
look at this
are you trying to jump yeah
look how sweet the lady is she brought
it up for us that's cuny oh wow
oh man
that's the spot gonna check it out
como
comedokoro
oh the goods
all right look at all this good stuff we
got we got spam and egg oh spicy tuna
which one do you want can i get i can't
order a spicy tuna and it's famine right
i don't know how am i supposed to know i
forgot yeah because i'm in i'm in hawaii
so my brain literally shuts off i hate
it turn it back on nope
not on
i don't know
exactly this guy knows what i'm talking
about here
look at that which one do you want this
uh salmon
go for it you little monster all right
look at this this is cool you can open
it like this there's a little pull tab
right there
very japanese let me go like that
and then you eat it this one is the
salmon one
show me the inside buddy show me the
inside
my mom's gonna beat um you live the life
man you do live the life buddy
on the way we stop by pa
la akai bakery
because they have what do they have sean
snow puppies
and what's a snow puppy so they're these
um pastries filled with chocolate and
they got some like
uh
sugar sprinkles on top
super good that sounds bomb yup
i like the name too
sounds authentic okay we gotta show you
even though i don't know we gotta show
who shawn is because sean has big
rhinomay energy really and he kind of
resembles random a little bit a little
bit yeah yeah
but he's they're only gonna get his eyes
through the
the most perfect teeth i've ever seen
that's true
that's five years of braces for you
let's go five years
why so long how [ __ ] up
they were [ __ ] up my dentist just
didn't know what the [ __ ] he was doing
damn well they're perfect now do you
wear a brace like a like a little
retainer yeah retainer right i see
bricks you know the the teeth brace do
you wear the teeth braces there's
nothing permanent so i just wear it uh
when i sleep oh yeah that's what you're
supposed to do we [ __ ] that baby i
don't know what you [ __ ] up my
thoughts i got gas again very wet back
to normal
he's saying can you please be quiet i'm
so sorry dude take your nap
yeah but that's what it's called
oh she got the goods
yep she got the goods
all right they were on their next batch
let's see oh for reals yeah perfect time
we knew we were coming
let's see see we got in there
oh
oh let's see the goods oh they are
snowballs
oh monkey just walked up at the right at
the mecca time what are those
i smell sweets
look how cute this little town is
got a little restaurant welcome
a little restaurant bakery action over
here
look at that breakers
yeah we've been here before that's one
of those is there too yeah
got a little restaurant we got cholo's
out here what
where are my people at
north charlotte also different cholos
isn't it is it it might be the same
trolls go everywhere no
well i don't know not really full okay
we like to kick it in our town
look at this these cute little paintings
that's new oh
someone's awake
look at that
kokua general store that's pretty cool
love seeing all this oh look at all
these shackles whoa
look how big that shell is oh my
goodness this guy was on a mission to
find shells
we gotta come by and
we gotta get one and tell grandma you
found it
look at whoa that's a giant seashell
monkey
monkey all right now we're walking down
this walkway
to the super secret beach
you're gonna look for seashells
do you even know we're at a super secret
beach mister
[Applause]
look how cool this is
so you walk down this little walkway
come here got some rules
about sea animals and then
boom
look at that
walk out here only one other family
because i think most of them are private
beaches
and wow
[Applause]
that is insane
[Applause]
holy moly
right when we walk out there's a turtle
right there
look at that guy
that's cuny
hey monkey you see the turtle
are you gonna climb to come see the
turtle
you see
it you see it
okay don't run okay be careful
be careful
be careful duty
yeah you see it yeah that's so cool huh
he's not daddy sleeping
hey what are you doing
the water's coming oh no i'm just
kidding
over there little turtle turtle yeah
right there
oh wait that one right there yeah
there's a little oh i see it right there
little turtle right there
yeah right there a little turtle right
there hey
it got pushed by the waves
right there
there's two more right here three more
there's three more right there
right in the water right there
hey he popped his head out
i popped his head out again
we got camp all set up
we're ready to go and papa
cannot wait
geo cannot wait fine
i do want to try it she wants to watch
me is it custard on the inside no i
don't want to watch you eat it i want to
eat my own oh i could already tell how
flaky it is it's super light yeah oh my
god you sure you don't want one dude you
got to take a bite here oh no look at
that here this is how the chefs do it
taste test oh my he's a man of
discipline okay
[Applause]
it was
you don't want one
you're crazy dude
are you
weird you jumping on me
what's happening
[Music]
the powdered sugar made me cough
and i coughed on his back
look at how clear
my goggles are it's insane
so this whole trip i keep forgetting i
keep going to the store and i keep
forgetting to bring anti-clock for the
goggles so i'm doing the good old like
spit technique rub it around
the thing is after about like five
minutes it fogs up so when i'm out
snorkeling i keep getting interrupted
because i have to clear my mask over and
over and over and over again
and i saw some spear fishers
a spear fisherman
some local dudes
and i was like yo you guys have an
anti-fog like no we don't use that they
use a leaf right there
so what they do
is they spin on the goggle take a piece
of that leaf get a little salt water and
rub it and this has been the clearest my
goggles have ever been look at this i
was like snorkeling around
for probably like a good
30 minutes
crystal clear
amazing
shout outs to the locals dude
all right so i'm gonna go
come on
all right so i'm about to go back out
there again
and i'm gonna do what the locals taught
me
we'll just use this leaf and there's a
fuzzy side too i spit get a little bit
of seaweed like that
rub it real nice and good
seaweed i mean what am i saying i don't
know
uh a plant flat flat leaf
sorry so discombobulated but get all
this because i'm in a bikini center in
front of you i get it
stupid let me see so when you're inside
in front of the key i like to rub like
this
i'm sorry
and then what happens you lose her and
then and then that's it i go like this i
go out there and it's crystal clear for
another good at least 30 minutes
someone's happy
so now in mine oh it's wet now
it's [ __ ]
uh no we're drinking that one already
yeah
so it's lunch time now
my sis got some poke
from food land and what is that garlic
yeah pickle garlic pickles show you
garlic is it because you know i love
garlic hell yeah we both do we're gonna
fart
we're gonna fart so much but we're
inside the denta now we're gonna bring
in all the sand
we're gonna do a little
a little huts a little hut action
and she brought some pog
yay
let's go baby
this would be a bomb ass lunch you want
to scoot over
nah all right which one should i try
first
this
so much
a little bit of rice i'm saying
it's the second one
what's this one
and then what's that
have you tried this before
it's delicious
this one yeah
you're gonna love it you know what this
is
it's soda you don't want coke
yes it is it's a little bit a little bit
i promise you're like it's a little bit
stop
stop
watching yeah
[Music]
you're just kidding
i do i do
why is it so reluctant in the beginning
okay
dinner time and we're gonna check out
this sushi place
called tadashi supposedly super good
authentic japanese cuisine sushi and bar
what in the world so we didn't even
order anything yet
they ain't messing around playing player
wow
thank you
how do you guys do this stuff
what the heezy
damn that's my favorite dude
so what's this is this like fried fish
skin yeah so it's fried salmon and
they've got like a real nice sweet sour
sauce to it
super good mmm try eat it with the
cucumber how long have you been working
here
super good
it looks so buttery
look at that
just got home took a hot shower feel
nice and relaxed
about to get ready
for bed and if you're ever in a wahoo
you have to go check out tadashi's
they are the cutest
couple ever so corey is the wife that's
one of the owners and then the husband
is this the sushi chef and corey is the
one that comes out and gives you all the
food
and they they just make you feel at home
you know like you go there
it doesn't feel like you're going to a
restaurant it literally feels like
you're going to a family's house and
they kept bringing out plate after a
plate after plate we had the uh the miso
uh based fish then we had the
hamachikama and then we had udon and
then we had uni and then we had a whole
plate full of sashimi
it was an endless amount of food and
they have everything there because it's
japanese cuisine so if you want noodles
rice fish cook dishes raw dishes they
have all of that and to top it off we
finished it with some really delicious
um lilikoi sorbet
and then some guava
and it was
yummy yummy yummy and
now that we're home i'm nice and relaxed
belly full of food as you can see really
good food and it's time for us to go to
sleep i'll mister
yeah
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
good night good night everyone good
night good night good night
oh you give me a kiss yeah